what i want to do in this video is
compare the fraction seven tenths to the
fraction eight ninths and like always i
encourage you to pause the video and see
if you can figure out whether these
things one of these is larger than the
other or whether they are equal
so for me in this video i want to think
about it visually and i'm going to do
that using holes of the same size that
are circles
so let me let me draw them or let me get
them here so there you go so these are
holes of the same size i'm going to
compare seven tenths of this whole of
this circle to eight ninths of this hole
which is a circle of the exact same size
if you're comparing seven tenths of a
small circle to eight ninths of a bigger
circle or seven tenths of a big circle
to eight ninths of a smaller circle or a
different shape then you really can't
make the comparison but we're going to
compare seven tenths of the same hole to
eight ninths of the same hole
now you can see the way that i've
pre-drawn it the circles are the same
size but i've divided them into a
different number of sections here since
i have tenths i've divided it into
you see that i've divided into 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 sections over here since
we're dealing with ninths you can see
i've divided into one two three four
five six seven eight nine sections
but let's think about what seven tenths
represents it represents seven of these
ten sections so let me color them in
so let me get my
my coloring in tool so it represents
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 out of the 10 sections
now what about eight ninths
eight ninths is going to represent eight
of these nine equal sections
one two three four five six seven
eight of those sections so which one of
these is larger
which one is larger
well you can see very clearly remember
we're using eight ninths of the same
hole and seven tenths of that exact same
hole you see that we have colored in
more in magenta or this pinkish color
than we have in blue so eight ninths is
the larger of these two or we could say
that seven tenths is less than eight
ninths and once again the way i remember
what symbol to use we always want it
opening to the larger of the two numbers
or the little the the tip is going to be
pointing to the smaller of the two
numbers so 7 10 is less than 8 9.